نبدا من تطورات اعتقال مراسل صحيفه
الخارجيه الروسيه ان اعتقال المراسل
مرتبطون بالتجسس مشيره الى انما كان يفعله
ليس له علاقه بالصحافه وقالت المتحدثه
باسم الخرجات الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان
مراسله
وبالجرم المشهوب المشهود عفوا اثناء
التسريب معلومات عن احدى المجمعات
الصناعيه العسكريه الروسيه واستخدم تصريحه
كغطاء لانشطه غير صحفيه وقد اعلن الكرملين
ان ملف المراسل بيد الامن الفيدراليه
من جهتها نفت جورنال اتهامات موسكو
لمراسلها وطالبت بالافراج عنه فورا وتم
اعتقال المراسل ايفان جيركوفيتش واحتجازه
في ياكاتره
اعلنه جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي كان
اخر مقال نشره مراسل جورنال يوم امس في
صحيفه وول ستريت بشان التحول الاقتصاد
الروسي الى انهيار والتقلص الميزانيه
وانخفاض الاستثمارات
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه مرحبا
بك هل من معلومات اكثر تفصيلا حول حادثه
المراسل مراسل جورنال
مرحبا خالد بالفعل اليوم جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي كان قد اعلن عن انه قام باعتقال
المواطن ايفان والذي هو طبعا
مراسل صحيفه هول
الامريكيه في مدينه
تتحدثوا عن توجيه اتهامات له بسبب
الاعمال التي وصفوها بانها تجسسيه على
الحكومه الروسيه بانه يقوم بجمع معلومات
عن مجمع الصناعي العسكري هناك وهذا ما
يعتبر سرا للدوله كما علق عليه الكرملين
قال انه
تم القاء القبض عليه متلبسا واما المتحدثه
الرسميه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا كانت قد قالت انه ليست هذه المره
الاولى التي تقوم بها الصحافه الغربيه تحت
مسمى صحافه
باعمال تجسسيه داخل الاراضي الروسيه وكما
تناقلت وسائل الاعلام
بعض وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ان هذا الصحفي
كان قد وصل الى روسيا من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في عام 2017
عائلته كانت قد هاجرت من الاتحاد
السوفياتي الى هناك ومن ثم عاد هو الى هنا
ليعمل كمراسل هنا في روسيا كان يغطي
الاعمال التي تعلق طبعا بالعمليه العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا وريكاني يقوم بنشر
مقالات تحليليه وتحقيقيه على صفحاته في
مواقع تواصل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي هنا
في روسيا كما طبعا تعلم خالد ليست فيها
هذه الحاله الاولى التي تقوم طبعا روسيا
اصابع اتهام الى
ايضا كانت وجهت اصابع الاتهام وايضا بتهمه
التجسس على لمواطن امريكي في بدايه العام
الحالي كانت وجهت له تهمه جمع معلومات
بيولوجيه هنا في روسيا بالاضافه الى توجيه
اتهامات لمواطن بريطاني كان قد القي القبض
عليه ايضا
في في تهمه ايضا التجسس وجمع معلومات عن
الجيش الروسي خالد شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
ايضا مراسله العربيه كاتيا الطعمه